JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, among
other things, you've
been learning about
computing components
of one vector in the
direction of another vector.
So I have a
straightforward problem
about that for you here.
So we've got two vectors.
The vector 2i minus 2j plus k.
And we've got the
vector i plus j plus k.
And so what I'd like
you to do for me
is to compute the component
of this first vector
in the direction of
the second vector.
So why don't you pause
the video, take some time
to work that out, come back,
and we can work on it together.
Welcome back.
So hopefully you had some
luck with this problem.
Now this problem is
pretty straightforward.
Really all you have
to do is remember what
the definition of component is.
And after that,
it's smooth sailing.
So in particular, the
component of one vector
in the direction of
another is the length
of what you get when you project
this vector onto that one,
well, plus a sign, right?
So if the projection is
in the same direction,
then it's positive, or if it's
in the opposite direction,
it's negative.
So let me draw a picture
of what I mean by that.
So if you have a vector v and
you have another vector w,
then the projection
of v onto w is
what you get if you make a,
drop a perpendicular line there,
and then it's just
this vector here.
So that's the projection.
And then the component is the
length of that projection.
Again, with the
sign if necessary.
And so we can see
since this is going
to be a right
triangle here, we can
see that this vector
has length that's
just given by the length of
v-- so the length-- rather,
the component of
v in direction w
is-- so it's just the
length of v, right-- that's
the length of the hypotenuse--
times the cosine of the angle
between them, so it's
times cosine of theta.
Now this length of v
times cosine theta,
this should remind
you of something.
This looks very much
like this formula we
had for the dot product, right?
So another way of
writing this is
to say that this is
equal to v dot w--
so v dot w is the length
of v times the length of w
times the cosine of the angle.
And so here we just
have the length of v
times the cosine of the angle.
So we have to divide this
through by the length of s.
So this is what
the component is,
and this is the
simple formula for it,
if you're given v and w
in some easy-to-use form.
And indeed in this
problem, we're
given v and w just in their
nice coordinate forms.
So we're given that
our vector v that we
want the component of
is 2i minus 2j plus k.
And the direction w that we're
looking at is i plus j plus k.
So in our case, we just have to
compute these expressions v dot
w and the length of w in order
to put them into this formula,
and then we'll be done.
So in our case, v dot w--
well, that's straightforward
because we're given v
and w in coordinates--
so this is just 2 times 1 plus
minus 2 times 1 plus 1 times 1.
So that's, OK, 2
minus 2 plus 1 is 1.
And the length of
w-- well, you know,
it's just your usual
length formula--
is 1 squared plus 1 squared plus
1 squared, the whole thing is
square rooted, which is equal
to the square root of 3.
So we've got v dot w and
we have the length of w,
and so then we just need to put
them right into this formula.
That the component of
v in the direction of w
is given by this expression.
So the component of-- I'm
not going to write it out
with i's, j's, and k's,
I'm going to write 2,
minus 2, 1-- in
direction [1, 1,  1]
is, well we just have to divide
the dot product by the length
of the direction vector.
So that's 1 divided by
the square root of 3.
So that's that, I'll end there.